[Music]
[Applause]
the singers that took over America's Got
Talent quarterfinals live on the Dolby
theater
[Music]
opera singer and Daniel Emmett brought
the house down with his epic performance
of Aerosmith's I don't want to miss a
thing in Italian while Christina Wells
belted out an incredible rendition of I
am changing Mel B was brought to tears
during two performances as us the duo
sang a song they wrote for their baby
girl who's on the way
[Music]
made me really emotional
you wrote this song to your baby get and
after contestant Michael Ketterer 'he's
hurt felt performance of James BAE's us
that closed out the show Simon Cowell
even got choked up
[Music]
that's dad you know I can't imagine what
you darlings the fact that you were on
this show and and you really need this
you're really really special guy cry too
much use you're just an incredible
person an incredible human being to do
what you've done taking on board
adopting all these kids and giving them
life and then you'll do your voice sings
such truth and honesty I was trying to
hold it secure you yeah I was actually
yeah because that normally doesn't
happen to me but there's something about
my girl and now I've got to know it or
what it means to him and then you
reminded you know with the tape and
everything and because I'm a dad as well
it was yeah what was it about it what is
it about Michael's story that kind of
you connected with the most what gotcha
it's his sincerity kindness you know and
what he started to change those kids
life and then he puts it all out on the
line you know tonight and I know and I I
really fell for him you know he's a
really really special person we're in
emotion right let's talk about the end
there I mean I don't think I've ever
seen Simon that emotional before not on
television at least to take by surprise
no because I believe what I've gotten a
note Simon personally over the last
couple of years and he is and I don't
think people know that what kind of a
human being and what kind of a father he
is and what kind of a friend he is and
he's the biggest off and he doesn't do
it for the cameras
[Music]